dieu c'est trop tard pour vous piquer
chez s'est jamais trop tard pour
s'impliquer
je veux v10 pas ni ma meilleure amie on
faisait tout ensemble
mais vous avez parfois tendance à
l'excentricité
mais elle est devenue maman formidable
moi j'étais seulement patine pièce on
m'a fait prêt c'est parce que ça dit là
dessus je n'avais pratiquement pas de
photo sans musique
elle était toujours là
manque déjà
millie la tumeur est maligne
qui fait quoi à l'heure des d'âge tu as
un souci
faut que je commence ma chimio genre
tout de suite
un truc localisé en plein dans mon corps
ouais
just le présente sam sam voici jesse may
très vieilles copies ilana une grosse
seringue
j'ai l'air d'un mutant qui se souciera
demi mois
la couleur une kim va bien que théo vers
le haut vers le vin
tu devrais lui dire ce moment j'ai pas
trop envie de lui est allé mon bonheur
son nez je sais que tout le monde se
réjouit de cette débauche de bouffées de
pouvoir mater ma perruque non j'ai pas
encore crevé alors je dirais que ça sept
7 ans
chauffeur vous emmenez là s'il vous
plaît c'est pas la route pour rentrer 4
dire que celle aventure pourquoi tu pas
embarqué dans cette galère
elles sont
non non on regarde je te mets des niches
ou non un peu plus gros s'il te plaît
maman
allez au dessin on va refaire le
pansement j'espère que le paradis existe
tu crois qu'ils le seront en traînant un
mois qu'ils revoient les critères de
sélection la baisse